Peter King Mike Florio talking about
some of the things that we either didn't
get to during KFC live or that we would
like to talk about some more and we
spent some time talking about Peters
interview with Bengals coach Zack Taylor
they drafted Joe Borough first overall
last Thursday night and look Peter a
year ago Joe burrow was a guy who had
spent a season at LSU had a 57%
completion percentage was pissed off
about it went back to the lab to improve
his mechanics specifically his footwork
getting his feet set when he was off
platform his completion percentage
skyrockets to north of 76 his yards
nearly doubled his touchdowns go from 16
to 60 his team goes 15 and OH
he wins the Heisman Trophy and he
becomes the no-brainer number one
overall pick in the draft so now the
challenge is getting him ready to be the
quarterback for the Cincinnati Bengals
when we consider this crazy upside down
environment we're still inhabited and
there's going to be no offseason program
by all appearances who knows when
training camp is gonna open what kind of
a challenge of the Bengals really faced
with here to get Joe borough ready to be
there week one starter well the crazy
thing one of the things I wondered with
Zack Taylor is you your quarterback who
and and who knows maybe Andy Dalton
stays and takes the first snap of the
year but for all intents and purposes
your starting quarterback going forward
might not even meet AJ green until
mid-august I mean what sort of problem
is that and you know what it reminds me
of a little bit Mike it reminds me of
those stories that you hear about
Russell Wilson like and and quite
honestly Joe burrow going to Auburn you
know in the middle of the summer and
then doing enough in summer camp to win
the starting job or like Russell Wilson
you know 19 days after he lands in
Madison Wisconsin he's named one of the
captains of the team and he gets the
starting quarterback job and he has a
great year that is what it's going to
take this year for Joe burrow to be
really good but compounding the problem
is the Zach Taylor mentioned to me look
he's going to get all the stuff mentally
when we go over it
on these teleconference things when he
has like quarterback meetings and and
all that so he'll mentally he'll know it
but you've got to do it you got to go
out and throw Andy any sand and look I
know because I asked the dad you know
Jimmy Borough Ohio University isn't open
and Athens high school isn't open those
are the two big football places where
the borough's live in Southeast Ohio and
so he's gonna have to find a field
somewhere in the area just an open field
to throw to people and he's gonna have
to find people to throw to maybe old
Athens High teammates but there's so
much about this that's gonna be a 34:31
day I can't even imagine and you know
you say he may not meet AJ green until
August I continue to be very very
curious as to how all quarterbacks and
their receivers tight ends running backs
what kind of arrangements they will make
especially before the world opens up
again because I already suspect that
some of that stuff's going on and people
are just being discreet as opposed to
what they were being a few weeks ago
when they were posting evidence of it on
social media but if you're Joe burrow
and you want to take charge of that team
you're gonna want to get together with
AJ green you want to get together with
with John Ross you're gonna want to get
together with tee Higgins you're gonna
want to get together with Joe Mixon and
really start working on getting yourself
ready to play and it's that that
mentality at Chris Sims shares from time
to time on pft live football players
just don't care maybe they should but
they don't they're not worried about the
corona virus they're confident that if
they get it they'll be fine they're not
thinking about all the potential
implications of passing it around their
families they are young they are
invincible they are strong and they are
going to do what they have to do to be
ready to go play football period so you
know there's the stuff we know about
Peter but I also think there's gonna be
the stuff that that we don't know about
and if the seasoned pros like Tom Brady
may be doing it
Joe burrow is gonna find a way to do it
too
probably so and look I think as we've
talked about before you know Tom Brady's
gonna find a way to get Mike Evans and
and Cameron braid and Chris Godwin up to
his place up in Montana and he's gonna
throw to him at some point and and I
would expect that the Bengals are gonna
try to do that with burrow and these
guys somewhere but at the very least
Mike they're gonna have to wait a little
while I think because of local
ordinances and you can't be together but
this is this is all such such a mystery
right now and that's one of the things I
was saying to somebody the other day
look I've now been a sports writer for
40 years and one month okay this by far
is the most intriguing time and the most
interesting time that I've ever been a
sports writer and III wake up every day
and think about nine things that hey I
should look into this I should look into
that so we just don't know what's gonna
happen but part of that is so intriguing
if we don't know what's gonna happen
that's what kind of makes it interesting
yeah there's been a formula every year
and I've been doing this 20 years now
every April is the same every May is the
same every June is the same it's
different names it's different twists
but it's always that same cookie cutter
on the NFL calendar and now that we've
gotten through the draft which was the
focal point for weeks the cookie cutters
are thrown out the window we have no
idea how this is gonna play out we have
no idea which teams are going to master
this new reality which teams are going
to be kicked to the curb and we can just
at this point only hope that we will see
football at some point this year and
look uh uh it's it's amazing when you
listen to some of the folks in the media
who just want to want to fire darts set
at the sports writers and the
broadcasters who are trying to be
realistic and suggest that we're being
pessimistic no we're being realistic
we're being objective we're looking at
this situation and recognizing it's
going to be different for everybody and
there is a chance there isn't going to
be football this year
as part of the the coverage that we have
to devote to this so we hopefully will
see Joe burrow with the Bengals Peter we
hopefully will see all these players on
the field but I think it's ridiculously
naive at this point to assume it will
happen without complication without
delay without the possibility that it's
just not going to happen at all I agree
and the one other point I think you
really have to consider in all of this
is and it's look it's with it's with
every rookie every rookie is going to
have a different process this year then
a normal rookie would have to me it's
one of the reasons one general manager
told me Saturday night when I said hey
how's it going and he goes you know
we're really really happy with the
intelligence of the guys who we picked
and I said explain that and he goes we
don't have any idea what these guys are
gonna go through before the season
starts so it doesn't it stand to reason
why we want people who are really smart
so that the indoctrination period both
mentally and then on the field is gonna
be a short one and you know you don't
want to be taking a lot of time if you
only have three weeks of practice before
your first game teaching all the
remedial stuff to a guy who has to play
for you and so that I think is gonna
show I think some of the best rookie
years we'll see this year we'll look
back Mike in January or February and
we'll say oh my god Kol commit was great
for the Chicago Bears because he picked
up stuff seamlessly and he adapted
quickly and that's what's Joe burrow has
to adapt quickly and seamlessly you know
for the Bengals to have a chance this
year yeah and it's all to be determined
and there's no formula there's nothing
we can look at there's no statistic
based on their past play that we can
really say aha here's the evidence
especially since burrow struggled his
first year at LSU if he had made that
transition from Ohio State to LSU and
had the year he had last year right out
of the gates then you've got evidence of
it but with a lot of these guys we just
don't know and we won't know but we can
hope and that's what we'll do and
continue to provide you with all the
information you need about what's
happening in the NFL on PFC live on PFT
ot and all of the various NBC sports
platforms thanks as always for some of
your time and we'll see you back here
again on Thursday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports